It's really important to use analytics
with monetization because you really
want to understand your users.
So as an app developer, knowing
more information about your users
will allow you to tailor it and
change things and tweak things so
that you can try to figure out, okay,
why did someone stop at this level?
Maybe it was too hard for them, or maybe
you have to offer an in app purchase, or
something like that.
That allows them to really understand
how to get to the next piece of
monetization.
Right?
So the more data that you have
the more it helps you understand, okay
what do I have to do to tweak my app to
get to the next phase of your business.